[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vraiment il ya signe d'amour savoir
général vrai rendez vous ça te sers de
mon chéri ben ça va super contente une
couche touche pas la barbe du monde
occupe maintenant j'ai beaucoup de
vannes bonsoir ça marche
merci bonsoir on est à un an de la
présidentielle
et beaucoup de gens ont laissé penser
que cet homme se présenterait à
l'élection
r il envoie pourtant des signaux clairs
qu'il n'a pas envie d'y aller
alors une fois pour toutes non syrie
n'est pas candidat pour quoi
voilà c'est la banque ont quand même su
cohabiter ça veut dire en fait et en
fait comment pas compris quand ma grand
mère a voulu mettre en route la cheminée
sam il faut pop et à une tuque noire
ouvert les community managers ils ont
plusieurs comptes souvent ils ont un
compte perso tessa c'est toujours être
intelligent côté s'il était depuis très
fort c'était c'était broad m'étais ne le
fait pas chez vous bien évidemment du
québec après ça j'ai envoyé des messages
subliminaux personne ne va se dire après
cette séquence il m'a convaincu oui je
la prends on n'imagine pas une
allocution de cyril hanouna française
sans ses tubes et du cul voilà le sujet
l'oms et gilles verdez ça va très bien
voilà passé un bon week-end ça va ça va
pas crier sur nos invités comme ça
combien de fois à la baisse j'ai une
longue et rien n'est jamais payé sylvie
j'y crois pas déjà y en a pas
les chrétiens alors moi ça m'a rappelé
ma jeunesse gilles parce qu'on a une
passion football
oui c'est un joueur que j'adore et qui
s'appelait ariel ortega ouais et quand
j'ai entendu j je me suis dit que ça
aurait pu être un très bon commentateur
de foot regarde pas répondu contexte
quand tu cries ortega ortega sur un
invité carton rouge
ortega ortega ça peut bien passer la
grosse polémique dans la fin de la
semaine c'est l affaire pépite away le
pp taghit ça les amis beaucoup n'est pas
de manger des bananes
cyril oui tu as retrouvé pepita jelade
hors jeu
on aime tous surtout retrouver peppy
temps c'est un exploit tu aurais pu
retrouver le trésor des templiers qui a
témoigné par téléphone dans l'émission
est là tout le monde s'attendait à ce
qu'elle tire dans la gueule de patrice
laffont et des chroniqueurs de pyramide
au lieu de ça elle a pris tout le monde
à contre-pied pour vous faire une
analogie regarder voilà le tireur ses
pépites à le gardien c'est nous on se
dit elle va la mettre grosse frappe en
pleine lucarne dans la gueule de
pyramides et la quotidienne
elle a pris tout le monde à contre-pied
mais mme rokhaya diallo frangine
du coup elle elle pense à autre chose
rokhaya elle sera mangée à la rudesse du
pool est dit est vrai ce 2e je pourrais
faire une quiche
il faut que j'appelle aussi sophie faut
que j'appelle sophie voilà voilà ça va
s'appeler la prochaine fois vraiment ça
sert à rien st gall a marqué un beau but
quand même alors on sait qu'il ya des
problèmes de racisme à la télé vous
savez les arabes et les noirs ça fait
longtemps qu'on regarde cet outil est
heureusement que l'émission qui a
dévoilé ces faits est irréprochable
grâce à yann barthez qui est l'empereur
où vous allez admirer pas le match et
non premier employeur de noirs en france
comme vous pouvez le voir sur cette
photo où regarder
voilà c'est rempli de renoir ou alors
c'est vrai que c'est assez monocolore
mais ne soyons pas mauvaise langue
séries tu sais que je t'aime beaucoup
j'ai cherché et j'ai trouvé le noir qui
travaille chez quotidien regarder voilà
il s'appelle mamadou c'est le chauffeur
rumeurs qui travaillent à la production
il viendra vous chercher à 21h15 ne
vient pas lui mettre cinq étoiles pour
tout ce qui est raciste mais dans les
années fier comme pour le combat des
femmes laisser les gens concernés en
parler c'est mieux bonne soirée
merci merci